everyone has to follow our next guest
if you're not already she's been a
friend of mine for years actually and
she's a mom
and an author and in charge of all
things fashion
on instagram please welcome eva chen
oh i know oh eva
oh god i love you so much i'm so happy
this is a virtual hug
because i miss you so much i know it's
like oh
i'm such an affectionate person and this
is just such a wild time but it's going
to teach us
valuable lessons i know it actually
speaking of learning valuable lessons
how's homeschooling going how is zoom
school tell us
everything i have like glue sticks here
in front of me
and various school supplies i am in full
prep mode
and it's a little bit of a nightmare i
mean i have not gonna lie i've cried
i always had respect for teachers but i
have like next level respect for
teachers now i'm like teachers need to
be paid more
but i also know that i am not a teacher
and i've been um this has been a
humbling experience i'll put it that way
i'm right there with you eva i cried so
much
i found strengths i didn't know i had
one of my things that i've always loved
with my girls is reading books and we're
big juno valentine fans
which is one of your books and now you
have a new book which is called
roxy the last unisaurus rex
yes and one of the things i loved
was you have a son and a daughter and
you wanted to find a book
that appealed to both of them tell us
about that so my daughter has always
loved dinosaurs uh
and she had a playdate with a friend
once and told her
you know girls don't like dinosaurs and
she was heartbroken so i wanted to write
a book for girls
that had unicorns and dinosaurs two of
my daughters favorite things
combine them into one and create a book
that every kid could love about
finding their place in the world how
it's great to be unique
and to be yourself and just to
unapologetically
revel in who you are eva you're really
doing it all
and i love that you admit that you ha
it's hard
and yet you're accomplishing it and that
humanization of all of the amazing
things that you're doing in life i think
makes us all feel like we can do it too
you're so prolific what is going on in
the world of fashion
may i please specifically ask you about
masks because i want to show a couple
pictures
of you on your instagram with ren in
particular
what do you think about the whole mask
thing well i think when it comes to
masks first of all it doesn't have to be
the blue kind of surgical mask that we
get at the doctor's office i think it's
really important to have fun with masks
listen we're trying to keep everyone
safe for me i have elderly parents
that are at risk and so i'm always going
to wear a mask in public i will always
be the one who like
gives people the stink eye when they're
not wearing a mask or when i read an
article about
college students gathering in a 300 in
one dorm room
it gives me like the chills because it's
all about protecting
other people a mask is not necessarily
comfortable especially if you live
somewhere hot and muggy and humid
but i think of it as a public service
another thing that i heard was that you
were juggling your
family and work and all of the stuff and
that even to get in the fashion
and walk the streets and in a true
instagram moment it's like how are you
doing all this you were saying it was
just hard to juggle it all and get it
done
not gonna lie drew i'm totally wearing
like bike shorts but i did put on makeup
for you today which is a big
deal dressing up once in a while just
for the heck of it
putting on a new pair of earrings
putting on a new necklace
but dressing for comfort but trying to
find ways to add a little bit of fashion
like i love your earrings today oh thank
you well you know
that's funny because um lee harris uh
the incredible stylist i work with
we talked about what was the look of
this show i'm not playing a character
i'm playing me
but i only wear free city sweatpants and
rubber sandals
so i didn't think that that felt
appropriate and i do think that we
are going to find an inner inspiration
to make the world a runway and express
ourselves
more than ever when we come out of this
and it's nice when moms who are looking
at your instagram account are like she's
doing that and
the reality and the fabulousness to me
are a very potent combination about you
eva
and i just love and respect you have for
many years
missed the famous eva chen pose can't
wait for it to come back
and everybody roxy the last unisaurus
rex
is in bookstores now